[Music]
google cloud offers external https load
balancing with global and regional
scopes it distributes http and https
traffic to packets hosted on a variety
of google cloud platforms such as
compute engine google kubernetes engine
cloud storage and so on as well as
external backends connected over the
internet or via hybrid connectivity
in google cloud a backend service
defines how cloud load balancing
distributes traffic to its packets
this table lists the various backend
types and the features supported by
global https load balancing in different
modes in this video we will focus on how
to create and configure a backend
service with an instance group and a
global external https load balancer
let's jump into the google cloud console
and get started the first step is to
select load balancer tag go to load
balancing page and click create load
balancer in the https load balancing
section click start configuration select
the option from internet to my vms for
external load balancing
next
choose global https load balancer click
continue enter the name of your load
balancer for example
web dash map http now let's configure
the backend service click back in
configuration under back-end services
and back-end packets click create a
back-end service
enter name of your backend service for
example web dash back-end
service since we are creating a backend
service for instance groups set the
back-end type as instance groups choose
the protocol as http and named port as
http timeout represents the amount of
time in seconds the load balancer waits
for your backend to return a complete
http response before considering it a
failed request we will now configure the
backend under new backend
select instance group
in our example we will select lb dash
packet
enter the port number as 80. balancing
mode determines where the back ends of a
load balancer can handle additional
traffic or is fully loaded
for https you can select utilization and
define
maximum back-end utilization if all the
back-ends are instance groups
select rate and define maximum rps if
all the back-ends are either instance
groups or zodial links with capacity
scalar you can scale down the target
capacity without changing maximum
utilization or rps value
click done you can enable and configure
cloud cdn and cloud security policy as
required now let's configure an
important and mandatory parameter health
check
click create a health check enter a name
for your health check for example http
help check select the protocol as http
by default the request path selected is
root but if you want you can set a
specific request path as well as
expected response string you can turn on
health check logs if required and set
the values for check interval time out
healthy and unhealthy threshold click
save
enable login to view logs for https load
balancing backend servers you can
configure whether to log all requests or
randomly sample fraction using sample
rate it can be set through 0.0 through
1.0 where 0.0 means no requests are
locked and 1.0 means 100 of requests
along now let's explore the advanced
configuration option session affinity
allows all subsequent traffic and
requests from an initial client session
to be passed to the same server
by default it is disabled you can choose
session affinity type based on your
requirements
in client ip connections from the same
source and destination ip address go to
the same instance in generated cookie
connections with the same load balancer
generated cookie go to the same instance
in header field affinity the proxy
hashes the value of a specified header
the header field's name must be provided
in the packets consistent hash this
option is not available in classical
balancers in http cookie affinity
requests are routed to back ends based
on the http cookie
this option is also not available in
classic load balancers connection
training timeout is the number of
seconds a training instance will wait
for in-flight connections to complete
with custom request and response headers
you can specify additional headers that
the load balancer adds to https request
going to backends or to the proxy
responses coming from the backends we
will return the default settings in this
demo and click create congratulations
the backend service webdash backend
service is configured successfully and
is ready to be used in global external
https load balancer for more information
on backend service configuration check
out this documentation thanks for
watching
[Music]
you